you can rent a cabin right on the lake
then you've got a pontoon boat and you
just keep it for you know you go out
there they got a lot of trout in the
lake fish trout I make some trout
Piccata would you like to have some
trout Piccata never yeah you know what I
do to make the trout Piccata I mean this
is gonna be gross whatever you say it's
some some kind of thing about how you
defile the corpse
well it's called cooking
and um what you do is you take you you
catch the trout all right you clean you
got the trout
them press them down clean the trout
what does that mean it means pulling
their [__] guts and getting their
heads ripping their [__] body cutting
their fins off remembering scraping the
scales off and then you uh homicide you
you shove them you shove them down spine
down and take the [__] bones out as
best you can and then you're going to
want to get that
oh